[Music]
Christian
the blue okay good
evening welcome to the table we're so
happy to have you here and also happy
last day of
Pride so my family and I we celebrate
Pride as a lot of us um all year all
year but it's it's fun to have a a
special time that they they they take a
month and and and owledge it means a lot
to Suzanne and I so for for sure it's
just speaking for us we're so glad that
you're here um so beginning tomorrow
we're entering in our season of downtime
here at the table uh in order to
facilitate a spirit of rest and
recuperation in our community we
encourage our Meetup teachers uh leaders
excuse me to take a break as well we
intentionally schedule a few if any
events a few folks who uh are who see
quite often will be taking a break for
the entire month namely Brett Maggie and
Mindy with that in mind we have some
wonderful guest speakers and worship
leaders filling in so we encourage you
to be here Sunday during uh this time
our Sunday evening services will be here
so um and I forgot to introduce myself
my name is cat and my pronouns are her
and
she the city of saxis red white and blue
blast firework show each year and it's
coming up this Wednesday July 3rd the
fireworks begin at
9:30 p.m. but you will walk want to be
there around 8 or 8:30 uh or 9: to get
settled in and get you a seat if you
would like to sit with the table members
you can join uh other table members you
can join the at the table Facebook group
and Allison Huff
woodan had to ask her of her
pronunciation um she will have details
there on the fa at the table Facebook
group she
um where she is oh she'll put details of
where she'll be sitting so that
everybody can meet for the
fireworks and uh you can find a link to
that Facebook group by scanning the QR
code as you're able or willing will you
please stand as we enter into our time
of
worship now we exit
the kingdom of
noise hurry and
productivity
now we enter the kingdom of
Silence
Stillness and
Grace now we enter Sacred
Space a space for
prayer worship and
adoration a space to encounter Christ
revelation of God heartbeat of
creation may love find
you find
us may we all come
home we're going to start off tonight
with um a song based out ofs
it's
A6 can you guys hear me okay I can't
hear myself either
[Music]
sorry they are working feverishly back
there I can see the faces like hold on
we're trying we're trying you guys are
doing great thank you for
trying let me know if I need to do
something on my end yes
[Music]
can you guys hear
me hey oh we hey all
[Music]
right well I don't even know what was
heard or what wasn't that I said but
we're going into Psalm
116 it's great song so you guys sing
along with us um if you know it and if
not just let these words sink into your
soul I've been kind of reflecting back
on some Psalms this week that have just
um been kind of like threads through my
life you know like there's certain
scriptures or maybe maybe for you it's a
song that you've always gone back to
that just comforts you in times where
you're um just feeling like you need
some stability and um for me Psalm 121
is one of those talking about The God
Who Watches Over Us and cares for us um
I lift my eyes to the hills where do my
help where does my help comes from
that's one of the Psalms for me that's
encouraging this song um is based on 116
and it just has some beautiful words
from that scripture so just let those um
just let them soak into your heart as
you sing tonight and maybe like cat was
saying earlier let it quiet some of the
chaos and let it bring some of the Peace
of God's spirit and his
presence I love you
Lord for you have delivered
[Music]
me I love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I I will
walk in the land of the living my soul
from Death my feet from stumbling I will
walk in the land of the
[Music]
living o
I love you
Lord for you have delivered
[Music]
me I love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the L and of the living my soul from
in the land of the
[Music]
living sing I bless you Lord I Will
Bless You Lord For You Heard My Cry I
reach out my hand and you saved my life
I will bless you Lord for you heard my
and the god of Heaven turned his ear to
me I will bless you Lord for
unending love for your grace and mercy
raining down from above I Will Bless You
Lord to the very end I will call on you
as long as I may live I love you
Lord for you have delivered
me I love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul
from my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living
[Music]
[Laughter]
beautiful picking Gary thank you guys um
kiddos y'all are dismissed to go to your
classrooms thank you kids team who will
be caring for our kids tonight and
loving on them and teaching them the
love of God we appreciate yall
[Music]
and as they exit we are going to
transition into the prayers of the
people and if this is your first time
with us tonight um this is a tradition
um that's throughout Christian history
and it's a space in our service for us
to offer up and name some of the things
that we are carrying on our
hearts and you can join in when you see
words in red and then um we'll leave
some space for you guys to name what you
might be carrying
Jesus for this city of saxi Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to
[Music]
you Johnny
Owen Chelsea
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
[Music]
amen you broke my chains of sin and
shame and you covered me with good
face you
my Holy Fire you covered me with
Grace you are the head that reaches out
to
save I am set
free I am set free
it is for
Freedom that I
am set
[Music]
free you broke my chain oh sin and shame
and you cover me with gra
you me my life with your Holy Fire you
cover me with
Grace you are the hand that reaches out
to
sa I am set free
oh I am set free oh
it is for
Freedom that I
am set
[Music]
free I am set free
oh I am set free oh
oh it is for
Freedom that I
St
[Music]
fre and yes Lord we are grateful for
your grace and For Your
Love Yes Lord we are
Greatful for your grace and for your
love yes Lord we are grateful for your
grace and For Your
Love Yes Lord we are
grateful for your grace and for your
love you are the heav that reaches out
to say
I am set free
oh I am set free
oh it is for
Freedom that I am set
free I am set free oh oh
I am set free
oh it is for
Freedom that I am set free
[Music]
you set fre
come Tear Down the Walls
build the fever you want the fil up cuz
you deserve every piece in my heart
every peace in my heart every pce of my
heart
come and Tear Down the Walls build up
every wall build up everyone build up
cuz you deserve every piece of my heart
every piece of my heart every piece of
My Heart
Lord I am trusting that you are faithful
father all the you have it is
good you're a generous GI for your L
like no other once you come and break
through to me over and over over again I
am bringing my heart to you with open
hands closer and closer your draw him in
as the depths of my heart lay before you
again over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer you draw me in as the
deps of my heart lay before you again
and
Lord I am trusting that you are a
faithful father all that you have it is
good you're a generous SK your love's
like no other you come and break through
to me over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer you draw me in as the
depths of my heart lay before you again
over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open head
closer and closer you draw him me in as
the depths of my heart before you again
[Music]
come and Tear Down the Walls build up
every W build up every W buil up cuz you
deserve every piece of my heart every
piece of my heart every piece of my
heart come and tear down the walls are
buil up every wall buil up every wall
buil up you deserve every piece of my
heart every piece of my heart every
piece of my heart
[Music]
God thank you that we can bring every
piece of our life before
you both the good and the
bad the things that we're celebrating
and the things that we're
grieving the things that we're proud of
and the things that we are ashamed
of and we can lay it all in the light of
Jesus knowing that in that light comes
Freedom comes forgiveness
[Music]
hope God thank you that when we walk in
the light as you are in the light that
we have a fellowship with you and with
others that you're a safe
place you are a home you are a refuge
and a
shelter you are a rock
and an
[Music]
anchor God we bring our whole lives
before you
[Music]
tonight every
peace thank you for accepting us for
loving us for pulling us forward for
healing our hurt places
for calming our
storms for forgiving our
[Music]
sins God would you keep tearing down our
walls so that we can live as children
who are loved children who walk in the
[Music]
light children who are known and seen by
a good God who is on our side
[Music]
Jesus it's in your name that we pray
these
things
amen would you guys turn to the people
around you and say hello and then Brett
will get us started on our message
well Grace and peace it is so good to be
with you all my name is Brett pronounce
he him and
uh and uh yeah I'm just I'm really glad
to to be with you to welcome you um into
this space and that is um true for
everyone but as always it includes those
joining us online love you all Lots
thinking James Townsen who's always our
our host so Faithfully James if you've
ever been online and watched the service
you know James Townson is there week
after week after week after week after
week after week after week I mean for
years and years I think from the
beginning of the table or really close
to it I mean like yeah so um love you
lots James really grateful for you um
and also I want to welcome anyone who is
new thanks for for being
here so um
before we jump in I want to to kind of
reiterate something cat mentioned so um
we take the month of July as a church to
kind of have some just sort of a rest
Rhythm so you'll notice like aside from
that uh event that was mentioned about
the Fourth of July like fireworks thing
that's sort of like our only aside from
Sunday service that's like the thing
we're going to do outside that there
like nothing going on and that's very
much by Design um there's you know
there's there's rhythms of of work and
productivity I mean June was kind of a
big month for us we had all sorts of
child dedications and events and this
and summerama and you know all that and
then there's a time to kind
of you know to use the farming metaphor
let the land lie fallow you know and we
all need those kinds of rhythms and so
we have that as a church there's a time
for connection and doing all the things
and all that and there's a time to kind
of chill so July is that for
us is that for us and so um so just know
um so I'll be out um Maggie
uh will be out and Mindy we for the
first time kind of our little household
um we're all like we're we're out at the
same same time and um yeah so if you
need something email Karen Theta tx.org
she is here for you I did have her
permission I mean she told me like
redirect them to me you know um so uh
yeah and we'll be back in August and uh
ready to ready to roll
so um we are in the the last message of
our series titled holy shift 21st
century faith and kind of throughout
this series we've been looking at all
sorts of things um topics that just felt
timely and relevant you know from
consumerism hustle culture entertainment
digital culture and life and distraction
all that we just you know all sorts of
things and so uh and kind of looking at
how these things tend to draw us away
from kind of you might even say just
ourselves you know from like in thus
from God and so we've been looking at
how do we shift back how do we move back
towards um our Center back towards the
god whose love um how do we come home to
who God's called us to be and so that's
so we've just been looking at a number
of of shifts that we we need to make and
uh so tonight is uh the last one I want
to look at and it's um it's titled holy
shift selfie
culture and um our scripture is Matthew
chapter 16 veres
24-2 then Jesus said to his disciples
whoever wants to be my disciple must
deny themselves and take up their cross
and follow me for whoever wants to save
their life will lose
it but whoever loses their life for me
will find it
so Twitter and the
BBC two big authoritative organizations
they declared 2014 to be the year of the
selfie it was the rise of all sorts of
things it was sort of the rise of the
smartphone with the whole front-facing
camera was like taken off and then you
had Instagram taken off and so of course
people you know it was kind of a became
a way to sort of track your life you
know I mean to kind of record those
moments on the highway of life you know
it's just so quick to just kind of go
hey you know snap the selfie and and
kind of
document uh your your journey and uh and
just to be clear you'll notice the title
of the message is selfie culture I'm not
really picking on selfies per se I don't
think it's you know like how dare you
take a selfie that's so self-centered
you know uh not necessarily I mean
sometimes just you know just it's
convenient you're documenting and
snapping and you know I mean um but I
want to do is kind of take though think
of it more metaphorically because there
is something that's a little bit
different about a selfie than like a
normal photo right you're taking usually
a photo it's usually centering kind of
others or like a
landscape you know but a selfie usually
just by nature of the length of your arm
or even if you use a little stick you
know like who's kind of like in the
middle of the photo who is the photo
primarily about
it's you you know I mean even if that's
not even your heart that's just kind of
the nature of hey there's like my giant
forehead and the thing and then you know
it's sort of everyone else in the
picture is like the the Robin twoyear
Batman you know it's sort of like it's
kind of just by nature of it's it's it's
there's something kind of centering of
the self there and um I I think seen
kind of from that perspective the selfie
it's a great metaphor for 21st century
culture because if you think like of the
culture in general and if even if you've
been here for some of these messages you
can kind of see how what's kind of the
thread running throughout you know
whether it's it's it's kind of the
pursuit of
entertainment um kind of digital
distraction whether it's it's um hustle
culture uh you know kind of consumer
culture what's what's kind of the the
thread running throughout
me like it's the self it's it's it's
kind of all about me my my
entertainment my
convenience My Success my winning my
comfort my it's kind of it's kind of
about me uh back in I think it was like
early high school went on a number of
these we did some mission trips with my
youth group and uh
memories I went to harez
Mexico maybe some of you did similar
trips and uh and you know I I will say
like I mean I have all sorts of thoughts
and about mission trips and there's kind
of I don't know weirdness but um the
good there was the good part of it I
would say for me was it was really um
well there was just something about
going and serving others you know and
I'll just say you know for this middle
class teenager upper middle class white
guy you know that was it was like a win
you know it was decenter me but I'll
never forget one trip in particular so
the kind of Rhythm was we would go and
usually we would like uh serve and like
do you know kind of construction at
least as good as middle schoolers and
high schoolers can do construction I
don't know if they just paid someone to
go back and like okay redo all this tape
and bed mess you know I don't know um
but we kind of do that during the day
and in the evenings we would hang out
there with the kids at the orphanage and
uh beautiful memories and connections it
was wonderful uh but each trip had like
a a theme and it would often be like on
the T-shirt you know that we kind of got
for the trip and so I'll never forget
like the first night the leaders all
like gather us in a circle you know
we're sitting there and they're like
okay we're going to reveal the theme of
the trip and usually the themes were
like inspiring or something you know um
this time the theme was they said all
right theme of the trip
is it's not about
you that was the theme of the trip it's
not about you and we were like fun all
right and and they said there's going to
be times you know the the food's not to
your liking you're hot you know whatever
it is we don't want to hear it because
this week it's just not about you it
just isn't you're like but it needs to
be no this week it's not about you and
sure enough like the theme it just it
kind of caught on I mean you almost
couldn't complain without someone
looking at you and just being like it's
not about you you know it just kind of
got into it so I can't speak for
everyone who went on that trip maybe for
some people I don't know I could imagine
someone who's like coming from a really
damaged place you know they're actually
like maybe that could be hurtful I again
for this this guy it was like a good
message because right what is kind of
consumer culture in like 10,000 ways
even from there when I was like you know
eth grade or whatever I was at like even
from just then 10,000 advertis ments and
messages and
slogans well catch I mean what were all
all what was all of that communicating
the opposite it was it's all about you
it's all about you it's all about you
it's all about you I mean this is how we
sell things to people it's about you you
you you and so what a
powerful
disorienting moment countercultural
moment
uh can you kind of
see um how this just makes its way like
that message of it's all about you just
kind of makes its way
into
US Theologian Maggie Ross writes these
words she says as a church as
individuals we must renounce what the
culture holds dear self display
self-pity self grander M self image self
self self self
self now here she's uh she's talking
specifically kind of like I've been
about the broader you know culture she
also writes quite eloquently about how
this this whole centering of the self
self self self me me me me me me me
makes his way into the
church uh she says there's kind of
different forms of this sometimes
there's kind of the grotesque version um
which has a good kind of post
Evangelical I can I can pick on um
because there's I would call it it's
well it's on display in like what I
might call for like of a better term
like cool
churches um maybe you've been to a cool
church it's like where everyone is um on
stage you're like they're all
beautiful you know what I mean it's
almost like that's is that a requirement
you're like okay so you're interested in
the worship team right well number one
are you good
oh God okay well no sorry you can't be
up here you know there weird right so
there's sort of like everyone's like
young cool beautiful well-dressed above
average
incomes or at least trying to
project that they are young and cool and
hip and you know what I mean and all the
thing and and what's that what is that
what's going on there
self self self it's it's about it's
about me and if it's about we well it's
a weird kind of institutional egoic we
you know
it's it's the it's the
self it's a religion gone a you
know but there's even another layer to
this it's it's even seen in kind of
popular Christian
piety um really any kind of form of of
spirituality in general I'm thinking
specifically you know Christian
that just kind of keeps us a little bit
self-obsessed
self-centered like even Um this can
happen with like guilt and shame you
know where I'm just sort of constantly
inwardly am I Measuring Up am I
measuring up I'm not sure if I'm
measuring up am I how am I how am I
doing am I should I be experiencing more
of God I feel like I should be
experiencing more of God am I
Experiencing God right now I'm not sure
maybe am I Experiencing God as much as
they are are my prayers being I don't
know if my prayers are being answered in
the right way I'm just oh God I'm very
worried you can tell this often by your
journal entries anyone gone back and
looked at their old journal entries you
know just I don't know if you've been in
this kind of culture you you the the
journal entries are again very you
know just God I don't know if it's it's
self self self self me me
me and I think we get it's it's like a
form of we get trapped in this
this um the the word Maggie Ross uses is
um
self-conscious we just get
self-conscious and and that's the
worst to be so like in a sense too aware
of yourself is is bad you know like it
just saps all of the joy out of life
right and and we what happens coming
back to culture broadly we live in a
culture that is
deeply in a church culture in a way but
we we live in a culture that's
perpetuating in deepening self-obsession
and self-consciousness it's sort of the
Shadow side of we think it's awesome
like oh it's all about me it's all about
me but then the shadow side of that
kicks in which is it's all about me it's
all oh no you know like am I am I
Measuring Up am I am I hip enough am I
cool enough am I you it's almost the
secular version of the Christian thing
we're talking
just so so so so so so it just eats Us
Alive poor souls that we are lost in the
hell of
self which um leads me to my big idea
for tonight as a society as a
church we desperately need a shift from
self from selfie culture we'll call it
to self forgetful culture if if if
obsessing with the self is like the
worst self-conscious you know just
that's the worst first what is Grace
what is peace what is Joy oh it's just
a just forget about myself right which
is different than neglect you know I
mean I'm not saying abuse yourself and
put yourself down you're nothing you
know no no no because that's just the
same thing coming in the back door I'm
trash I'm worthless I'm nothing that's
what the pastor said he said be self
forgetful it's just not about me and you
know no no no no no no that's a bad
interpretation that's just more of the
same no no no to
just just forget just let go it's kind
of the Paradox of almost like no one can
really ever ask you if you're happy and
you answer positively because the moment
someone asks you if you're happy well
you just now you're reflecting on
yourself again and so now it's sort of
I'm not really sure you know it's almost
like the only way to be happy is to like
oh sh just live you know like don't
reflect to am I really Joy I'm just not
sure if I'm really H if I'm happy enough
I'm just you know I mean it's the same
like oh no no don't do it don't fall for
it we desperately need this shift from
self-aggrandisement to self effacement
from
self-obsession to self releasing I'm
going to read Matthew 16 again now I
want you to hopefully hear it with new
ears then Jesus said to his disciples
whoever wants to be my disciple must
deny themselves take up their cross and
follow me for whoever wants to save
their life will lose it but whoever
loses their life for me will find it can
you hear that with new ears now I think
we often hear that language again in
quite a negative sense you know deny
yourself take up that cross lose your
life and it almost like we we hear that
in a sense of um like is there is there
something or someone that you love some
activity that brings you
Joy oh well that's a sin that's what the
Lord's calling you to give up you know
what I mean like that's kind of how we
hear like God wants me to lose my life
like is there is do you have peace and
joy and a heart of service well give
that up that if you're happy that's the
right can you hear that's almost how we
hear it lose your life like no no no no
no can you hear now what we're actually
losing we're like we're losing the hell
we're losing the
worst we're losing the the
traps right and this is where even that
phrase coming back to that mission trip
story it's not about you again we can
hear that even as like a very negative
it's not about you you're so selfish and
you're so you know I mean but actually
what did I find on that trip it's
wonderful to for not to be about me I
like oh it's awesome it's not about you
that's it's almost we hear it oh it's
the worst no no no it's the best it's
the best it's like good news it's not
about you you know what I mean it's
almost like a but in a consumer culture
we can't but hear that in a way that's
like
what huh this is good this is good news
you know oh yes the best you know it's
it's so
countercultural see to deny yourself to
lose your life it's not about hating
your life no no it it's not about
rejecting your body or hating sex or or
despising a good home-cooked meal oh how
selfish of you enjoying your life no no
no no no now you see following Jesus a
life with God is actually the process of
learning to take my eyes off
myself off myself it's learning to shift
my gaze outward toward others God all
creation by gaze of course I don't mean
literally your eyes you know I'm talking
about the the mind your focus your
attention again Maggie Ross she says
once again life in God is so simple and
that's precisely why it is so difficult
because it's so much easier to focus on
the complexities of the pseudo life of
our
self-consciousness our own personal soap
opera that's a good turn of phrase or
the distractions that are resistance
offered by our sloth on the pressures of
the culture our pretentiousness our
grandiosity our vanity our narcissism
life in God it's so
simple and thus so difficult
I love this phrase pseudo
life pseudo life or put a bit
differently fake life like that's the
thing Jesus is inviting us to give up
that the soap
opera the drama the ongoing blah blah
blah story of this and that and that's
wrong and this and that I just I just
not measuring up and that why is I going
it's all that that's what we're being
invited to let go of Jesus isn't asking
us to die to the best most profound
experiences of life like I mentioned
earlier peace Joy service connectedness
he's not no it's not that's not what
we're giving up he's inviting us to die
to Ego life self-conscious life fake
life and of course the trick is at first
it can feel to put it metaphorically a
bit like a
crucifixion right there is a sense of
profound loss of like oh my God because
we've built our whole life on this stuff
who am I without my soap
opera you know I mean like who am I
without my well I'm GNA hustle and win
and make a million bucks you know or who
who am I if I'm not like competing or
winning or who who Am who what am I what
am I what my God you know it can be this
is profound for people like oh this is
why Jesus cast it in that paradoxical
light you know oh yeah it'll feel like a
a losing of yourself a denying of
yourself so to
speak but it's so that you might
live so that you might enter in maybe
like for the first time in your life
into true Joy you might ask who would I
be without all of that
who will I be let me answer that
happy that's you you for the first time
you're like
peace because there's something so
beautiful so simple as Maggie Ross said
just simple about just
living just living I'll close with the
story I uh I had a great little moment
with my nephew Judah he's
nine and um as many of you know I we
live our we have shared living so my
brother and sister-in-law live upstairs
with their four kids and we live um
downstairs with our three kids so it's
like it's a full house you know and uh
so I went down he he took up soccer
recently and so I go downstairs one
Saturday morning it's like the the
Saturday of his his first game you know
so he's there he's got his whole little
cute uniform he's the armor dillos
that's his team name the armor dillos
adorable so he's sitting there he's got
his cleats on which is hilarious walking
around the house his cleats you know CL
black and he sits down he's just
chomping way to seral he's just
like and uh I said hey buddy I said hey
you excited for your first game and
without even looking up he just goes
yeah I said uh well how how are you
feeling you know and he said
fine and I said well I'm trying to get a
little Le the servant you know what I
mean so I said well you are you feeling
nervous at all and he goes
huh I said you know first game
Jitters and he just looks at me he goes
what do you
mean and I was like well well at this
point I hesitated because I didn't want
to like make him nervous you know I mean
he's like perfectly fine like oh well
you should be real anxious like I would
be you know I didn't want to project all
my anxiety onto him on his behalf so I
kind of hesitate but he honestly he
seemed so fine he was just fine so I was
like well okay let me bring him into
Loop about how most people feel about
these things so I was like well you know
people are nervous for not only their
first game but honestly every game
because you know like they want to win
or they just you want to make sure they
do good or they'll be people watching or
whatever you there various reasons they
feel this way and uh I said you know any
of that kind of resonating with you or
something and he just looks back down a
cereal he just
nope and I thought to myself my good
he's more spiritual than
me I mean that's Pro it was profound
like because it was so simple you know
what I mean just going to play the
soccer
game just gonna
play that's it you know like in essence
it's it was the beautiful lack of
self-consciousness how I going to
measure up oh what if I trip over my own
foot what if I do that oh it's my first
game what if I don't know the rules I
look stupid What if I
I mean that all just steals the
joy of of course is about more than
soccer it steals the joy of our whole
life our whole
life and there's something so beautiful
about just learning right it's a process
learning
just let it go let it go and just simply
play so I want to invite you to yes in a
sense die to die to those soap operas
and dramas and selfimprovement
schemes and all you know but not just to
be negative I I want you to do that so
that you might truly
live in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen so as we come to the table of the
Lord tonight as we take in the body of
Christ in the bread the blood of Christ
in the wine I I want you to I want to
invite you to come forward in a way that
as best you can just kind of lacks
self-consciousness you know where you're
just simply here not looking for like am
I Experiencing God in the way I should
or am I supposed to hear something you
know or it's just like no no no just
just be here simple simple simple simple
simple just be here and let Christ meet
you
in this in his body his blood shed um
broken for for you so the way we're
going to do this is we'll just go row by
row starting here from the front we'll
form one line right here in the middle
um we practice what's called an Open
Table meaning if you're here tonight and
you'd like to participate you are free
to do that uh regardless of your exact
you know beliefs or denomination or
something if if something in you wants
to connect with the Risen Christ then
you're welcome to participate in this
time uh you should know the red is wine
the white is grape juice and then
finally you can just partake whenever
you'd like some people like to partake
right away others like to come and kneel
here at the front some return to their
seats and um partake there so however
you'd like to do that so this is the
table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so
come you who have much
faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to
follow and you who
failed
come come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the
table for
[Music]
that
good
[Music]
is
okay
[Music]
um would like to sing along with us you
are more than welcome to do so um we've
done this song before so many of you
will recognize it but um it's just an
invitation to become new let's live into
this message that Brett was talking
about where we let go of some of maybe
be our old patterns and self-centered
natures and allow ourselves to be a new
creation in Christ that has room for
what he has for
[Music]
us you are
not what you have
done or what
has been done to
you you are
something like the Rising Sun can't you
see that you are
new you might
have your father's
name or bear the
shame he left
behind but there's new life
flowing through your veins leave some
room to be
surprised you are
new every
morning you are
new Every Morning each day of
Resurrection waiting to break through
[Music]
[Applause]
oh you could
try just for a
start to put the
judge back on the
Shelf all the
loving
kindness in your heart have a little
for
yourself you are
new every
morning you are
new Every Morning each day
Resurrection waiting to break
through you think hope is lost but it's
just
underground the flame might be an ember
but the fight won't go
out oh the ID is pointing to the truth
each day the resurrection is still
happening in you you are
new every
morning you are
new every morning
you are
new every
morning you are
new Every Morning each day your
Resurrection waiting to break
through
[Music]
I you are new
you are
[Music]
new thank you so much for joining us
this
evening if you were visiting um or new
we would love for you to fill out a card
on that little table right over there or
to visit the the we the QR code and fill
out an online visitors card that way we
can uh you can learn any information
that you would like and we can say thank
you and and for
visiting uh if you in need of a prayer a
hug or just general support please come
find me after the service I would love
to be there for you however I can
[Music]
I don't
know okay I had to do that sorry I
taught Middle School way too long to let
that
[Music]
go uh here at the table we are committed
to creating an inclusive Christ centered
community that touches lives and
generosity is a key element of that
mission if you would like to join us in
supporting the work financially
you can scan the QR code on the screens
or out in the lobby or go to the website
at the table tx.org
all right let me send you into your week
with this
blessing you can hold out your hands and
a posture to receive or just open your
heart to these
words you are a child of God
you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
this is true on your worst day so as you
go into your week ahead with its yet to
be determined highs and lows and
everything in between go filled with the
assurance that you are loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's holy spirit
and a desire to extend these same Gifts
of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact
with be
blessed have a great week and we hope to
see you back here next Sunday
[Music]
you think hope is lost but it's just
underground the flame might be in but
the Fire won't go
out all the evidence is pointing to the
truth that daily Resurrection is still
happening in you you are new
[Music]
every morning